The one in the last,
which is on the right.
It's quite a horrifying image.
She know.
And that's a kind of a
devouring father figure.
And you know,
here,
here's a,
here's a way of thinking about that I,
which I think is extremely useful.
So you,
here,
you guys are in university,
you know,
and so,
um,
university is one of those patriarchal
institution that's gives with one hand
and takes away with another,
right?
So when you come here,
there's thousands of you,
there's tens of thousands of view.
So in some sense as an individual you're
rather faceless and you're also in some
sense at the bottom of the power
hierarchy in the university,
I think more than you should be.
But whatever you,
you are at the bottom of it.
And so there's,
there's a crushing institutional weight
that comes along with being part of such
a big university in particular.
You know,
that's really hard on
students in their first year.
You know,
it's always seemed to me that it's
better for first year students to go to a
smaller place where the
institutional weight is not so heavy.
And you know,
I've tested u of t students in their
first year with things like the Beck
depression inventory and about 30%
of u of t students meet criteria for
hospitalized depression.
They do,
you know,
but,
but that's also because the back is way
more sensitive to that than it should
be.
At least that,
you know,
because I don't think its criteria for
when you should be hospitalized are
reasonable.
But the point is is that the depression
and the anxiety is quite high.
And so,
but on the other hand,
of course you're benefiting
from going to university.
And so that's the kind of
bipolar nature of the symbol.
It's the tire town,
it's benevolent tradition.
At the same time,
you know,
it's molding you.
You could even say it's crushing you
because an educational system does that.
But at the same time it's like,
well,
unless you allow yourself
to get crushed by it,
you're not going to get the benefit.
And that's the paradoxical relationship
that individuals have with culture
everywhere.
And at all time.
You know,
without culture you're nothing.
But with culture,
you have to be a cog in some sense.
And so the tension between those two
things is continual and constant.
You could think about it
as an existential constant.
Ever since there's been
complex human societies,
and maybe even when there were
only tribal human societies,
that's been a problem for the individual.
So culture,
tradition,
the dominance hierarchy is a
solution and a problem and nature,
the unknown,
unexplored territory is
a solution and a problem.
And then the third category,
while you see,
I'll just tell you a couple
of things about these images.
So the one in the right,
that's the devouring father,
that's also giving birth.
So in some sense,
your personalities are being
devoured by the university,
but at the same time,
a new personalities coming
emerging as a consequence of that.
And hopefully it's a better
personality than the previous one.
If you can tolerate the
tension of being transformed,
the heat and the pressure,
then hopefully you come out,
you know,
you come out though,
it's worth it.
The process is worth it.